hi everyone and happy Monday hon David
Begnaud the national correspondent for
CBS this morning
and this is James clear he's the author
of a New York Times bestseller atomic
habits he's joining us now on the Toyota
green room to explain how you can build
good habits and break bad ones so I was
doing my research at home last night and
this morning and I thought oh I have a
few bad habits my first question I want
to start with is your book atomic habits
really focuses on instead of trying to
conquer the world at once start with the
most basic arguably the simplest and you
might feel like you're not really doing
anything but it works explain well so I
don't think this means you need to get
rid of your ambitious dreams like we
just want to summarize we could say when
you're making plans think big but when
you're making progress think small and
so atomic habits talks about scaling
behaviors down to the smallest possible
unit the atomic unit the little piece
that builds upon others and if you do it
right and you build a small habit and
continue to build those on top of each
other then compound and some more
remarkable results in the long run give
me an example well you can think about
this pretty much anywhere like most of
your results in life are a lagging
measure of your habits so your knowledge
is a lagging measure of your reading
habits so reading one page a day doesn't
seem like much but reading every day
turns into real wisdom over the span of
your life how do I create a habit to
read more well there are bunch of things
you can do one simple strategy is
environment design so let's say every
morning you make your bed instead of
just making your bed and moving on with
your day place a book on the pillow when
you go to get into bed at night books
waiting for you you can read a page set
it on the counter another example so
that's like physical environment design
digital environments this is my phone so
when I wanted to build a reading habit I
put audible and pocket so pocket allows
you to save articles to read for later
audibles audio books and I put those
right here in the in the main bar on my
phone so they be the first thing that I
saw that's new design with my phone up
now putting a book on the pillow or
changing your applications on your phone
like no that's one of those changes
probably isn't gonna radically transform
your habits
but if you make a few dozen those little
choices those little 1% improvements
well now all of a sudden you're living
and working in an environment where it's
much easier to read than it was before
one of my worst habits is getting off
the phone at night I just will get in
bed at 10 o'clock 11 o'clock I'm still
in bed on the phone on my sister
power down habits are hard for me too
that I feel like that's a tough area for
a lot of people what do you recommend I
know on CBS this morning you mentioned a
friend you have another author mmm who
has a strategy yeah he so he uses what's
called an outlet timer and basically an
outlet timers little device cost like 10
bucks or so and it's like an adapter you
plug it into the wall and then you plug
your device into the outlet and so what
he did was he plugged the outlet timer
into the wall and then his internet
router into it and then set it to kill
the power at 10:00 p.m. each night so 10
p.m. comes around internet goes off
can't watch Netflix can't browse the web
send emails time to go to bed and you
can actually now you can do a lot of
things like that with technology you can
have the lights in your house dim
automatically at 10:00 the internet
could go off and you know a couple
different things that are all kind of
like shaping you towards all right it's
time to like put this away go sleep but
it reminds me you have to be respectful
of those new habits you're creating sure
yeah and this is you know ultimately
these strategies like environment design
or things like that are ways to
accelerate that process a little bit or
make it like make it a little bit easier
but ultimately what you're looking to do
and this is something I talked about in
the second chapter of the book is you're
looking to foster a new identity right
you're looking to start to look at
yourself as someone who values sleep for
example or who like when I was in
college I had a rule where every if I
got to midnight and I was still studying
then I would just put the books away and
go to bed because there's always
something more to do like I could have
studied for another hour but once I
started to adopt that as part of my
identity I'm the type of person who goes
to bed at midnight every night then I
made sure I was getting enough sleep and
that was more beneficial in my view than
studying for an extra hour you talk
about when it comes to getting kids
ready for school and making them better
students in preparation for going back
to school that parents can do things
like okay yeah I'd love if my kid was a
book reader but I can start with not a
chapter but a page sure if we can do a
page a day it can be even shorter than
that you know for writing for example I
have a friend who's a
and his daily habit is to write one
sentence and there are plenty of days
when you know he has two little kids and
there are plenty of days when he writes
full-page or does even more but on the
bad days on the days when he's tired or
sick or stressed or didn't get a lot of
sleep you can still get at least a
sentence done I've had other readers who
have done similar things with exercise
happens you know like they there's this
one guy Mitch I mentioned him in the
book as well he end up losing over 100
pounds but he wasn't allowed to go the
gym for more than five minutes so for
the first six weeks he would just get in
his car drive to the gym get out do half
an exercise get back in the car drive
home and it sounds ridiculous right it
doesn't seem like this is the type of
thing that would make a difference or
get results but if you take a step back
what you realize is he was becoming the
type of person that went to the gym four
days a week right he was like mastering
the art of showing up and I think that's
a very deep truth about habits that's
often overlooked which is I haven't must
be established before it can be improved
right like if you don't have anything
that you're doing even if you if you
can't be the type person who goes to the
gym for just five minutes there's
nothing to optimize there's nothing to
improve you don't have any raw material
to work with and I think so often we're
focused on looking for the perfect
business idea the best workout program
the ideal diet to follow we're so
focused on optimizing that we don't give
ourselves permission to show up even if
it's just in a small way I'm trying to
get into the habit of swimming because I
want to adopt that as a new way of
exercising so I sign up for a gym
membership yesterday just to go swimming
yeah you know just to actually get but
I've been talking about it for a long
time so it's like okay just go sign up
mm-hm and then once you're actually
paying and it's coming to your credit
card you're gonna feel more obligated
with a lot of things like that so I mean
I think is a good example the hardest
part my dad likes this one my both my
parents do and he always says the
hardest part is getting in the pool yeah
but it's not actually the workout if you
get into your bathing suit that could
actually be the habit in writing cases
is like I'm not actually trying to build
a half of swimming I'm trying to build
the habit of changing into my suit and
if you do that like the swims gonna
happen right like you've almost you've
already kind of decided how the next
chunk of time will be spent
please scale it down to the very first
behavior Twyla Tharp the famous dance
choreographer and instructor she had an
exercise habit like that she said my
habit is not actually going to the gym
for an hour
every morning it's hailing the cab and
she just focused on handling the cap she
knew that if she got her clothes on and
hailed the cab the workout would take
care of itself listening you talk about
doing things that are arguably minimal
but are a step forward into creating a
good habit reminds me that as long as
I've been in journalism I've always
tried to figure out you know what can I
do to serve a purpose make a difference
and I used to for so long concentrate on
just tackling every story I could
possibly find out with my social media
and then I realized if you can focus on
one mmm even if it becomes the only
thing your audience is hearing and
they're kind of like why is he always
focusing on this you had the potential
to be more effective at serving a
purpose yeah reliability and focus are
very big things you I think one way I
would describe this is like so you have
time which is gonna pass anyway and then
you have execution or habits so the
amount of time what you're spending that
time on and then you have like strategy
which is sort of like this
I don't know exponent in the equation or
something and you think well if I had
the ideal strategy the perfect strategy
I could just like 100x my results but
the truth is if you're not executing on
something if you're not focused like
even if it's just on one thing the
million zero to the millionth power is
still zero right and so by focusing just
on one story you get some results even
though you might not think oh is the
optimal way to spend my time they can go
to questions before I wrap up if I were
to read the book and remember nothing
else
what should I remember I'll cheat and
give you two so the the first one is
about identity and the core idea that I
would say is every action you take is
like a vote for the type of person you
want to become so you know studying
biology for 20 minutes on Tuesday night
doesn't seem like much but if you do it
every Tuesday you start casting votes
for oh maybe I'm a studious person or if
you practice basketball three times a
week for the first week you may not
think of yourself as a basketball player
but six months or a year later that
starts to become part of your identity
and it's like every time you do this
little habit you reinforce this is the
type of person that I am and so I think
the real goal is not to read a book it's
to become a reader the real goal is not
to run a marathon it's to become a
runner
so that's really what we're talking
about when we talk about true behavior
changes identity change and then the the
second core idea is you do not rise to
the level of your goals you fall to the
level of your systems you know so often
we think behavior change is about
setting a big goal if I really wanted it
then I would do it if I had more
willpower than maybe then I'd make it
happen but it's actually about the
system of behaviors that you follow and
it's so easy to overlook those little 1%
changes of small daily habits but it's
that system that leads to the result
it's the you know what I've mentioned
early in the conversation your outcomes
are lagging measure of your habits your
knowledge is a lagging measure of your
reading habits your bank account is a
lagging measure of your financial habits
your weight is lagging measure of your
eating habits your clutter is a lagging
measure of your cleaning habits the
results come naturally when you build
the systems to drive them I love when I
heard you say that changing the words
you use like oh I have to wake up every
day at 5 o'clock to go to work I get to
wake up every day at 5 o'clock to go to
work it's a mental change but also note
the inflection that I use there I have
to wake up versus I get to wake up sure
ones more optimistic than the other yeah
I've been thinking about this more
recently these little mindset shifts do
you run the risk of making it sound like
oh just standard self-help just think
differently and everything will be fine
but they can be quite powerful
they give you a different way to
interpret reality and when your
perception changes your response changes
and so that's good suddenly all the same
things are happening in life I my kid
still gets out of school somebody needs
to pick them up it's dinnertime somebody
needs to make the meal but instead of
thinking I have to do these things and
seeing the circumstances in your life is
obligations you start to see them as I
get to do these things and you see them
as opportunities last question if you
were sitting here what would you ask
James clear hmm I think I would ask how
could i sustain a habit we talked a lot
already about how to start a habit make
it small make it easy and so on but if
you're focused on consistency on getting
happy to stick then all of these
strategies will still work to a certain
degree a habit is just like an exercise
and getting started each day so if you
make it easy to start you just do the
same thing tomorrow and you'll be able
to stick with it but there is a second
piece to this kind of puzzle which is
this
environment so we've talked about the
physical environment about digital
environment but the people that you're
around really helped have it stick in
the long run and I think the short way
to summarize this is that you want to
join a group join a tribe where your
desired behavior is the normal behavior
because if it's normal in that group
it'll be very attractive to stick with
the habit for the long run you know if
you hang out with a bunch of jazz
musicians suddenly it seems very normal
to practice jazz five days a week
because that's what everybody else is
doing
if you hang out and have a bunch of
friends who are CrossFitters now it
seems very normal to go to the gym
consistently because that's what all
your friends are doing so join a group
where the desired behavior is the normal
behavior games clear as the author the
book is atomic habits thank you so much
I'm I appreciate it to subscribe to
James's free newsletter visit James
clear comm is it sure you get two
million impressions a month yeah that's
right and very fortunate congratulations
very impressive where a guy from Ohio
right love those Midwestern folks hello
to the Midwest thank you for joining us
have a great day everybody